we got the story from CBS News
Anheuser-Busch CEO Brendan Whitworth
says financial assistance is being sent
to wholesalers beer distributors
impacted by boycott backlash let me
provide an alternate context for what
this information is first we'll take the
neutral approach the Anheuser CEO states
that they are giving money to people who
carry their beer let me make a little
bit a little bit more hyperbolic for you
the boycott was so effective that Bud
Light now has to pay people to carry its
beer
because let's ask this question why
would Anheuser-Busch send financial
assistance to wholesalers and
distributors
these Distributors could simply just I
don't know carry different beers like
shift their business reduce uh their
their Workforce say we're going to get
off Bud Light no this is an Ezra Bush
saying we're gonna pay you to keep
operating at this level
because we're going to try and pull out
of this one otherwise the wholesalers
say see you later
the boycott has gotten so bad that they
are now paying people to carry their
beer yeah and a job yeah it's it's
incredible to watch actually and on our
app the day after Bud Light that ad
campaign was released with Dylan
Mulvaney we saw an 800 increase in
searches for beer on the platform
because people are tired of it they're
actually looking for other options now
Modelo is the top beer above above Bud
Light and it was funny because some of
the media tried to paint it as like well
that's because people are done with
domestic beer that's why that's why bud
light's tanked and it's like dude all
these other domestic beers have actually
risen in value
exactly and so uh you know what's
interesting in all this is that we don't
think much about how the actions of that
man and uh the CEO of Anheuser-Busch if
you can't see the screen
um and his cronies and the ad campaign
agency out of San Francisco how much
that actually negatively impacted the
people caught in the crossfire of all of
this which is like the Distributors the
middlemen the sales people like they
absolutely got screwed because you
cannot sell this beer anymore have you
ever seen in the Dark Knight oh yeah you
guys you guys have seen that one
absolutely I love the fan theory that
the Joker's actually the good guy right
and the reason is by the end of the
movie he's gotten rid of a dangerous
vigilante Batman Batman retires he's
gotten rid of the mob and all the
criminals what the Joker did throughout
that that movie destroyed the the
organized crime in the city and
destroyed the Vigilante fighting it
it's crazy and then in the next movie
it's like he's been retired for a couple
decades I bring this up because what if
this Anheuser-Busch CEO is actually just
that he looks like the bad guy but deep
down he was sitting at his office and he
was looking at all the ESG and woke
stuff and he's like the only way this
changes is if someone pushes it over the
top and then a single tear rolls down
his cheek and he's like I will do the
right thing
he gets on his phone and he's like Dylan
Mulvaney and he's like we've got a job
to do and uh because because in this
interview apparently the announcer Bush
CEO has not ruled out hiring Dylan
Mulvaney in the future yeah it's absurd
and has doubled down on pride and has
said they will continue and they have
always been big supporters of this stuff
when your customers tell you we won't
buy your stock we won't buy your beer
and we will advocate for everyone not to
buy your beer to the point where you
have to pay Wholesales and Distributors
money to keep keep up their operations
you'd think at that point you'd be like
we're gonna listen to our customers and
get away from this stuff we're sorry he
won't do it no we're kind of through the
guild card he's like I'm really sad
because it really impacts the employees
who've been working they have pride in
this you know 165 year old company
that's been around forever like he is
trying to say people boycotting this
beer are the ones hurting these people
who work in their you know breweries or
whatever and it's like you made this
call you're not taking any personal
responsibility in fact you seem to be
willing to risk their jobs again it's
crazy well yeah his doubling down is a
controlled demolition like if he
actually feels bad for his employees he
has single-handedly caused that problem
by the way like I run a company you run
a company if something bad happens in
the company It ultimately at the end of
the day is is your fault because we take
responsibility for the company because
the buck stops with us this has been the
exact opposite blaming your consumers
for pain that's been put on your
employees rather than taking
responsibilities like the most low life
thing that I've ever seen a company
executive do the target scene is doing
the same thing right now and now for you
to paper over it with this house of
cards sham organization you've created
by having to literally do a rebate
program and pay people to buy the beer
just propping up the house of cards
further I have never seen anything like
it plus uh to your theory he was former
CIA and they specialize in regime change
so if he is if he is trying to topple
the woke regime maybe that is his
ultimate goal because it across the
board has decimated these World
Companies 50 billion dollars of market
cap dropped just between Anheuser-Busch
Disney and Target alone in the past two
months so I I have never seen a more
suicidal campaign from a company than
doubling down what about Public Square
what are you guys seeing uh the opposite
well yeah that 50 billion dollars has to
go somewhere like that's the interesting
thing is that these boycotts are only
effective if you can ultimately shift
your lifestyle spending away to
something else which is why we exist so
we created the app so that if you're
tired of Bud Light if you're tired of
Target you can actually go to something
else so that's why when Bud Light
toppled uh we actually 27 billion
dollars a market cap dropped we saw an
800 increase in beer when Target came
out and did what they did we released a
Target Shopping Guide that actually
drove our app to top five apps in the
entire app store for a week across all
genres so anytime one of these cultural
mediums for Commerce decides to be
insane work trying to be there to clean
up the mess and provide an alternative
so you can actually shift your spinning
away and what's happened is we've had
some people that said you know I said
that I was not going to go to Target for
June but I just couldn't imagine getting
Target away from my life in its entirety
and now they're saying I'm actually
finding my toilet paper paper towels
household cleaning products on Public
Square and I don't even need to do this
anymore and we have people asking us can
you open retail stores can we have this
literally be a replacement from Target
so that's where we're going but I think
the success of Public Square is a sign
of two things one is that the boycotts
are working and that people are tired of
woke Capital that's number one number
two is that people are actually hopeful
enough to go the extra mile to do
something different because the worst
indictment of our country in the
economic state currently would be that
if people either just kept shopping at
these companies even though they hated
them and these companies obviously hate
us in return or the other thing which is
that these people basically you know
boycott for a week and then lay off
because we don't have any other options
neither of those things are happening
people are actually shifting their
spending away and this is actually
working which is pretty incredible to
watch I think but Bud Light this is why
I made the joke about this guy being the
secret hero because what Bud Light did
was shattered the dam the cracks were
forming and then the CEO of Bud Light
just took a sledgehammer to that thing
and the floodgates have erupted and what
happens is for the longest time regular
people are scared if they speak out they
will get canceled they live in fear of
this especially younger people then
people noticed that Bud Light is tanking
and they think to themselves whoa
if I say something it's actually popular
now people aren't scared anymore now
they feel good now it feels good to go
shop somewhere else now you post a video
about how you're not going to Target
and what you get a million views yep so
there's even opportunists here we're
going to jump on board this is where I
think the tide shifts because the the
wokeness is falling into
it's falling into the lame cultural
space where it is it is it is becoming
negative it's not it's not interesting
and you know it is kind of what is kind
of interesting is if you look at like
punk rock stuff
these guys were dressing in very very
weird ways that were supposed to be
shocking to the average person you had I
think it was currently my wrong film Sid
Vicious wore the swastika yep yeah the
idea was to offend people to be like I'm
not a part of your thing then all of a
sudden Punk became cool and it became
mainstream and it became multi-billion
dollars how things kind of go
underground has totally disobed like the
actual underground is completely and
totally disappeared in the world of the
internet because part of the underground
used to be you had to physically go to
places to find this music you had to go
to certain record stores you had to go
to certain places to buy certain
magazines you had to go to shows that
were at certain locations it wasn't
presented to you and it wasn't given to
you so you had to put effort into work
for it I worked for it yeah then those
underground things became popular and so
here's what I think for a period you get
this rebellious anti-woke subculture
pushing back on the on the corporations
on Disney on Bud Light Bud Light the
number one brand
like all Trends in counterculture they
start to become more and more dominant
because people who are passionate about
these things believe in them don't give
them up and the average person just
doesn't care so what happens now Bud
Light went from number one to number two
Modelo is now number one and to be
honest Bud Light was always kind of a
number one haha it's very funny I'm very
funny and uh and now it's just crap it
always was but uh this shows that
regular people are are it's this Counter
Culture is now becoming more and more
dominant and moving into the mainstream
space my prediction is in a few years
this we win you know I don't know what
that means politically well I think well
obviously I think on the political
ramifications like if you want to know
how decisions are made in society look
at where the money goes and so if you
can shift The Profit structures of
society back toward the values of
everyday actual normal people uh I think
we win even politically but people ask
me often like do you think Bud Light can
redeem themselves at this point and I
think the clear answer is no because
they've become the butt of a cultural
joke like I saw somebody tweet recently
and it went super viral
um the biggest insults of 2023 is you
look like someone who would drink Bud
Light at Target and I'm like that's you
you're you're now screwed you see all
these funny videos going around of
people buying a Bud Light and it totally
Alters their personality it's like you
can't come back from that and I think
that what's really exciting about that
is people are waking up to have a
general sort of we talked about this
earlier there's an anti-establishment
sense in society at the moment that I
really Embrace I think it's wonderful
that should also carry into small
businesses so instead of going to Bud
Light why don't you go to a local Brewer
that's making awesome local craft beer
that a lot of this is actually super
affordable they don't hate you they're
not going to lecture you about gender
and it is that simple if you can do that
for all these different Industries like
on Public Square 90 of our businesses
are small businesses and it's great
because those are the ones that are not
going to lecture you about stuff they're
not bought into an ESG agenda or Dei
agenda and they're actually shifting
Society back to like normal people's
values people all the time ask like are
you political and I'm not political I'm
like a normal person from 2006 and it's
just the country somehow you've ended up
here exactly and so when Commerce has
become so politicized and we're we're
just trying to offer this solution that
is not going to tell you about gender
while you're trying to buy pants for
your kids like it's it's kind of a
refreshing thing for people so you're
seeing normal people wake up and you
talked earlier about how like the social
issues of gender are becoming such a hot
button political topic for the mama
bears 70 of American consumers are moms
yeah so if you get that audience pissed
at your brand and ready for an
alternative like that's our number one
demographic on the app it's 70 moms
because if you have the mama bears
mobilized to a product they believe in
they're going to tell other friends
they're the best evangelists for things
and alternative is true if they hate
your brand if you become the Target in
their eyes they're gonna thank you well
that's why influencer marketing
initially started with like Mommy
bloggers right they were on the internet
and being like here's my life and people
were like what products you use tell me
everything you do because I am looking
for your recommendation I think that is
an army that uh Bud Light did not think
maybe they should have courted the moms
instead of Dole Mulvaney they should
have been like well they were trying
they did that commercial with uh that
actor and his wife and it's like the
woman is sitting on the couch and she's
on old and then that Miles what's his
face the actor grabs two beers and
cracks them open and dances over that
was like couples they didn't like Chase
the moms they weren't like that was
specifically targeting women that was
like report covered in like the ad
marketing news as this is how they'll
get women because typically Bud Light
would like it wasn't effective what I'm
saying is they should have gone harder
in the we're chasing mobs like they
should have been replacing all of the
stairs a wine mom they should have been
like you're a Bud Light mom my point is
they tried that ad it probably didn't
work so they went Don Mulaney yeah
Market to kids I guess that's a good
conclusion to Market beer to children
but light wasn't exactly or isn't
exactly a great tasting no no it's
number one thing I don't think they
realize number one moms I think I think
that's a a fallacy but I think it's
important to note that women control
spending in most households that's not
yeah that shouldn't be a surprise to
people I mean that's been the standard
for for as long as I can remember when I
was a kid I heard stories that women can
do most of the Chicago do most of the
grocery shopping and and purchasing for
the household because they run the house
they also typically control most of the
philanthropic giving too so any
Charities decided by women so
this is this strange Paradox where uh
women are constantly being told you know
men are oppressing you but really they
have all this power they control
basically American spending and they
don't acknowledge it's been alive for a
long long they don't acknowledge it and
that's that's what bothers that's
because it's not convenient
true I mean like if you're in a position
where like you know everyone's telling
you that you're oppressed and you're
you're you're the the second class
gender and yet you're still bossing your
husband around you gonna make a whole
lot of noise about no we we don't need
extra benefits from the government and
blah blah no you're gonna just shut your
mouth and you're gonna go ahead and say
it's fine let's cut I was gonna jump to
another story if you want to write oh I
should say Ali Wong has this bit where
she says like feminist ruins everything
by saying by by saying we can do
anything yeah stop talking don't tell
them thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time